many medical professionals on the
frontlines compare the conditions that
they face to what it's like in war zones
one Chicago emergency room doctors spoke
with our lead national correspondent
David Begg now during a few chaotic
moments on his shift
David what did you see because I hear
chaotic is the right word here well Gil
we had no idea that dr. Scott Sandlin
was going to answer the Skype call for
the interview in the emergency
department now there were other doctors
attending to the patients in need but
what you're about to hear may be one of
the most sobering and surreal accounts
you have heard from the frontline so far
this is the most scared I've ever been
Deena our doctor and it's not because of
me it's because I had a wife and a
two-year-old and a one-year-old at home
I don't want to expose them people say
it's our job not our job it's our duty
and that's what we signed up for that's
dr. Scott salmon
he's an emergency room doctor at Mount
Sinai Hospital on the west side of
Chicago I deal with gunshots every day
and trauma and crazy stuff and this is
the only thing that scares me how many
patients do you see on a daily basis
that are suspected of being Kovac
positive over 78 60 to 70 percent every
day we keep hearing that young people
are not as affected by this has that
been your experience you can tell it the
27 year old I intubated last week we had
no medical problems dr. salmon says
anyone arriving at the emergency room
now who has respiratory problems is
being treated as if they're positive for
kovat because doctors can't afford to
wait the three days that it's been
taking to get the results back so we do
deductive reasoning if the white count
is normal and their length of Teaneck
which is something that we looked at and
their x-ray it looks like Colgan and
their influence and negative its Kovan
oh we're having another Kovac come in
you want to see the set up before it
comes in please please so before we go
in we put it on down
as much P Pease we had respirators we're
gonna have them to innovate the patient
yeah I'll put a tube down the throat but
this is becoming all too common okay
what the box right here the physician
protection box as they call it is
something the doctors had made at a
local plastic manufacturer to help them
deal with the Cova crisis protective
gear is scarce here dr. Sam Lin says
especially masks bag this coated patient
who's coming in right now the suspected
COBIT he's coming by ambulance I assume
how critical is he there they're doing
CPR on him yeah he's busy dying alone
which is really sad and that is because
suspected kovat patients need to be
isolated it says dr. Chris Keller who's
using a respirator that he got from his
previous job and a filter that his
father who works in construction gave
him how you doing protection for
ourselves instead of masks so I got one
carry my pocket it's frustrating spell
the government let us down how you doing
thank you for asking
I'm not well it's not a joke I want
people to stay home this is the real
deal
are they still performing CPR no they're
dead there was no time to even test that
patient for covent but the precautions
were taken dr. Sam Lin says beside PPE
and a break this is what they need if
you have a friend or a colleague or or
anyway you know in the healthcare
industry who's working the front lines
just send them a text saying thinking
about you god bless you love you thank
you for what you're doing that's all we
need on behalf of a grateful country
thank you thanks Dave
thank you Oh David I was so struck with
dr. Sandlin when he said no they're dead
the simplicity in which he said that and
when he also said many times you don't
take your work home but you have no case
you have no choice but to take this home
it's really overwhelming overwhelming to
hear you'll always know that they
started yeah I want you to know they
started a GoFundMe page so they could
raise money to buy their own equipment
that's how scarce the equipment is and
they've gotten money and they've bought
it and they're using everything from the
painters masks to athletes goggles just
to do the job daily and they are exposed
to this from the start to the end of
their shift we can all say thank you
thank you David all right get thank you
that's a powerful piece there